welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half hour with
one piece of video but people see two
very different things
a man seen shooting and killing a young
father will not be charged because of
Florida's Stand Your Ground law the law
allows someone to use deadly force if
they fear they'll they'll be killed or
badly injured without requiring them to
try to escape the case is again fueling
a debate over that law on Friday for US
senators called on the Department of
Justice to investigate Meg Oliver
reports I was kissing on I'm trying to
bring him back but it was too late last
week Britney Jacobs boyfriend of nine
years marquise McLaughlin was shot and
killed in front of her the couple had
parked in this handicap spot
McLaughlin walked inside with their
five-year-old son
that's when 48 year-old Michael Drake ax
approached their car I mean he was
swearing at you McLaughlin returned and
forcefully shoved Dracut to the ground
McLaughlin backed up but within four
seconds Drake up pulled a gun and shot
him McLaughlin stumbled into the store
and collapsed in front of his son one
day later the Sheriff's Department
announced Drako was protected under
Florida's Stand Your Ground law and
would not be charged we will not
continue to let this epidemic of being
neighbor to confront and kill unarmed
black people and then say I was just
standing my ground it was just
self-defense
Drakkar reportedly has a history of
harassing people at the store for
parking in handicapped spots just two
months ago richard kelly says drake a
targeted him spewing racial epithets he
went to his truck he set out to shoot
you dead so I was standing right here I
told him I said if you gonna shoot she
Jacobs is still trying to comprehend how
her children lost their father during a
trip to the store I can stand and tell
them you know
settings going to heaven you know it's
all pretty much go say for CBS this
morning Saturday Meg Oliver Clearwater
Florida